here's the deal i'm looking i'm
picturing vanilla ice cream like you
know plain vanilla
but caramel sauce on top of that you
know watching them make it
they had the little bit of vanilla there
looked real good right i feel like you
could smell it through the tv
oh yeah well they said it taken it takes
an hour to make it would take us five
minutes to eat
yeah well again rocky brought some back
so that's good okay another thing is you
need to put in a bowl and
of course if you got a bowl cut like me
and david did back
oh man why are you bringing this up
apparently we had the same barber yeah
you and i okay or the same mom
apparently we're brothers from another
mother today you and i are bold cup
brothers
all right so we wanted to share that
with you guys all right david shared
that with me weeks ago
and i kept it on the desktop of the wsi
computer
to use every year 90 degrees our
official high for the day today
we'll see if that holds true because
it's all up to the national weather
service we're waiting on their official
numbers
66 overnight for the low temperatures of
course have been above average lately
we should be in the mid 70s for this
time
you know we've been above that and we're
also going to stay above that into next
week too even though we cooled down 94
degrees is the record on this date
set back in 1960 so we'll come close to
that but we're not going to reach it
we're going to challenge those records
at all 89 for sky canyon right now
centennial hills same for you 91 aliante
92 for north las vegas
91 sunrise manor and same for whitney
ranch
also green valley henderson 89 mountains
edge
86. same for you that are joining us in
southern highlands we got a lot of
viewers in southern highlands thanks for
watching us here on 8 news now 87 in
pramp right now at 89
also for boulder city 95 currently for
laughlin so
we're eyeing that system to the north in
the pacific northwest that's going to
track to the north part of our state
also into utah here it is carrying some
moisture along with it changing over to
snow but that's going to stay to the
north while we stay dry what we'll see
as it passes through is a cold front
that will slide through the region
and as it does the winds again will
shift from the north and it'll usher in
cooler weather that's why we talk about
cooler temperatures tomorrow with this
cold front there will be a series of
disturbances and weak systems that will
pass through for
this week but really nothing affecting
us other than giving us occasional wind
temperatures will stay steady in those
mid to high 80s but we're not looking
for a big warm up this week this time
around so
here are the wins that we're expecting
for this week thursday elevated winds
again
a little breezy as we head into your
weekend and into early on
next week wind advisories needed
probably not at least not right now
but we will see breezy winds occasional
winds like we said as we get through the
week so here's your evening planner
still some wind at 7 pm
sunny and warm at 85 degrees we'll be at
79 for 9 p.m
clear with also breezy winds at times
same goes for 8 news at 11
74 degrees expected by 8 news 9 11 so
temperatures will be mild even 11
o'clock
62 degrees tomorrow morning mostly sunny
winds um
excuse me not as strong for tomorrow
morning mid to high 70s tomorrow across
the valley centennials at 76
double sevens for north las vegas and
also spring valley
mountains edge included along with
southern highlands 76 boulder city and
87 for you
in laflin tomorrow so like we said
occasional wind this week
i'll step out of the way here and show
you those 80s mid to high 80s this week
not quite warming up to those 90's but
nice comfortable but still staying
above average we'll see on 8 news now at
5. back overnight
good